In the last video, I drew this
grid in order to understand
better the different
combinations of alleles I
could get from my
mom or my dad.
And this grid that I drew is
called a Punnett square.
And I looked up what Punnett
means, and it turns out, and
this might be the biggest
takeaway from this video, that
when you go to the farmers'
market or you go to the
produce and you see those little
baskets, you see those
little baskets that often you'll
see maybe strawberries
or blueberries sitting in, they
have this little grid
here, right there.
Sometimes grapes are in them,
and you have a bunch of
strawberries in them
like that.
That green basket
is a punnett.
That's a punnett.
Apparently, in some countries,
they call it a punnett.
I think England's one of them,
and you UK viewers can correct
me if I'm wrong.
And so I guess that's where
the inspiration comes for
calling these Punnett squares,
that these are kind of these
little green baskets that
you can throw different
combinations of genotypes in.
And these Punnett squares
aren't just useful.
If you're talking about crossing
two hybrids, this is
called a monohybrid cross
because you are crossing two
hybrids for only one trait.
It could be useful for a whole
set of different types of
crosses between two reproducing
organisms. It
doesn't even have to be a
situation where one thing is
dominating another.
Let's do a bunch of these,
just to make you
familiar with the idea.
So let's say you have a mom.
So instead of doing two hybrids,
let's say the mom--
I'll keep using the blue-eyed,
brown-eyed analogy just
because we're already reasonably
useful to it.
Let's say that she's homozygous
dominant.
And let's say that the dad is a
heterozygote, so he's got a
brown and he's got a blue.
And we want to know the
different combinations of
genotypes that one of their
children might have. So what
we do is we draw a Punnett
square again.
Let me draw a grid here and
draw a grid right there.
And up here, we'll write the
different genes that mom can
contribute, and here, we'll
write the different genes that
dad can contribute, or the
different alleles.
I didn't want to write gene.
I wanted to write dad.
So the mom in either case is
either going to contribute
this big B brown allele from
one of the homologous
chromosomes, or on the other
homologous, well, they have
the same allele so she's
going to contribute
that one to her child.
The dad could contribute this
one, that big brown-eyed-- the
capital B allele for brown eyes
or the lowercase b for
blue eyes, either one.
So the different combinations
that might happen, an
offspring could get both of
these brown alleles from one
copy from both parents.
This could also happen where you
get this brown allele from
the dad and then the other brown
allele from the mom, or
you could get a brown allele
from the mom and a blue-eyed
allele from the dad, or you
could get the other brown-eyed
allele from the mom, right?
When the mom has this, she has
two chromosomes, homologous
chromosomes.
Each of them have the same
brown allele on them.
They both have that same brown
allele, so I could get the
other one from my mom and
still get this blue-eyed
allele from my dad.
So if you said what's the
probability of having a
blue-eyed child, assuming that
blue eyes are recessive?
And remember, this
is a phenotype.
These particular combinations
are genotypes.
Well, in order to have blue
eyes, you have to be
homozygous recessive.
You have to have two
lowercase b's.
So what's the probability
of having this?
Well, there are no combinations
that result in
that, so there's a 0%
probability of having two
blue-eyed children.
What's the probability
of having a
homozygous dominant child?
Let me write that.
A homozygous dominant.
And now we're looking
at the genotype.
We care about the
specific alleles
that that child inherits.
Well, which of these are
homozygous dominant?
Well, you have this one right
here and you have that one
right there, and so two of
the four equally likely
combinations are homozygous
dominant, so
you have a 50% shot.
And we can do these
Punnett squares.
They don't even have to be for
situations where one trait is
necessarily dominant
on the other.
For example, you could have the
situation-- it's called
incomplete dominance.
Let's say you have two traits
for color in a flower.
You could have red flowers or
you could have white flowers.
And let's say I were to cross
a parent flower that has the
genotype capital R-- I'll just
make it in a capital W.
So that could be the mom or the
dad, although the analogy
breaks down a little bit with
parents, although there is a
male and female, although
sometimes on the same plant.
And let's say the other plant
is also a red and white.
The other plant has
a red allele and
also has a white allele.
So what are the different
possibilities?
Well, we just draw our
Punnett square again.
Let me draw our little grid.
So the child could inherit both
of these red alleles.
He could inherit this white
allele and then this red
allele, so this red one and then
this white one, right?
That's that right there
and that red one
is that right there.
Or it could inherit this red one
from-- let's say this is
the mom plant and then the
white allele from the dad
plant, so that's that
one right there.
Or you could inherit
both white alleles.
What I said when I went into
this, and I wrote it at the
top right here, is we're
studying a situation dealing
with incomplete dominance.
So what does that mean?
Well, that means you might
actually have mixing or
blending of the traits when
you actually look at them.
So if this was complete
dominance, if red was dominant
to white, then you'd say, OK,
all of these guys are going to
be red and only this guy right
here is going to be white, so
you have a one in four
probability to being white.
But let's say that a
heterozygous genotype-- so let
me write that down.
Let's say when you have one R
allele and one white allele,
that this doesn't
result in red.
This results in pink.
So this is what blending is.
It's kind of a mixture
of the two.
So if I said if these these two
plants were to reproduce,
and the traits for red and white
petals, I guess we could
say, are incomplete dominant,
or incompletely dominant, or
they blend, and if I were to say
what's the probability of
having a pink plant?
And now when I'm talking
about pink, this, of
course, is a phenotype.
So the probability of pink,
well, let's look at the
different combinations.
How many of these are pink?
This one is pink and
this is pink.
So two are pink of a total
of four equally likely
combinations, so it's a 50%
chance that we're pink.
And we could keep doing this
over multiple generations, and
say, oh, what happens in the
second and third and the
fourth generation?
Actually, we could even have
a situation where we have
multiple different alleles, and
I'll use almost a kind of
a more realistic example.
I'll use blood types
as an example.
So there's three potential
alleles for blood type.
You can have a blood type A, you
could have a blood type B,
or you could have
a blood type O.
What happens is you have a
combination here between
codominance and recessive
genes.
And I'm going to show you what
I talk about when we do the
Punnett squares.
Maybe I'll stick to one color
here because I think you're
getting the idea.
So let's say I have a
parent who is AB.
So that means that they have
on one of their homologous
chromosomes, they have the A
allele, and on the other one,
they have the B allele.
That's what AB means.
So the phenotype is
the genotype.
They're codominant.
They both express themselves.
They don't necessarily blend.
They both express.
That's an AB blood type.
Let me write this right here.
This is AB blood type.
And then the other parent is--
let's say that they are fully
an A blood type.
Let's say they're
Let's say their phenotype is an
A blood type-- I hope I'm
not confusing you-- but their
genotype is that they have one
allele that's an A and their
other allele that's an O.
So this is what's interesting
about blood types.
It's a mixture.
O is recessive.
O is recessive, while these
guys are codominant.
So if you have either of
these guys with an
O, these guys dominate.
If you have them together, then
your blood type is AB.
So what are all the different
combinations for these for
this couple here?
Well, you could get this A and
that A, so you get an A from
your mom and you get an A from
your dad right there.
And clearly in this case, your
phenotype, you will have an A
blood type in this situation.
You could get the A from your
dad and you could get the B
from your mom, in which case
you have an AB blood type.
You could get the A from your
mom and the O from your dad,
in which case you have an A
blood type because this
dominates that.
Or you could get the B from
your-- I dont want to
introduce arbitrary colors.
You could get the B from your
mom, that's this one, or the O
from your dad.
No, once again, I introduced
a different color.
And this is a B blood type.
So if I said what's the
probability of having an AA
blood type?
And once again, we're talking
about a phenotype here.
So which of these are
an A blood type?
This one definitely is,
because it's AA.
If you have two A alleles,
you'll definitely have an A
blood type, but you also have
an A blood type phenotype if
you have an A and then an O.
O is recessive.
So this is also going to
be an A blood type.
So these are both A blood, so
there's a 50% chance, because
two of the four combinations
show us an A blood type.
And you could do all of the
different combinations.
You say, well, how do you
have an O blood type?
Well, both of your parents
will have to carry
at least one O.
So, for example, to have a--
that would've been possible if
maybe instead of an AB, this
right here was an O, then this
combination would've been
two O's right there.
So hopefully, that gives you
an idea of how a Punnett
square can be useful, and it can
even be useful when we're
talking about more
than one trait.
So let's go to our situation
that I talked about before
where I said you have little b
is equal to blue eyes, and
we're assuming that that's
recessive, and you have big B
is equal to brown eyes,
and we're assuming
that this is dominant.
And let's say we have
another trait.
I introduced that tooth
trait before.
So let's say little t is
equal to small teeth.
I don't know what type of
bizarre organism I'm talking
about, although I think
I would fall into
the big tooth camp.
Let's say big T is equal
to big teeth.
So an individual can have--
for example, I might be
heterozygous brown eyes, so my
genotype might be heterozygous
for brown eyes and then
homozygous dominant for teeth.
So this might be my genotype.
And the phenotype for this one
would be a big-toothed,
brown-eyed person, right?
Let me make that clear.
This is big tooth phenotype.
And this is the phenotype.
What you see is brown eyes.
A big-toothed, brown-eyed
person.
Now if we assume that the genes
that code for teeth or
eye color are on different
chromosomes, and this is a key
assumption, we can say that
they assort independently.
Let me write that down:
independent assortment.
So this is a case where if I
were look at my chromosomes,
let's say this is one homologous
pair, maybe we call
that homologous pair 1, and
let's say I have another
homologous pair, and obviously
we have 23 of these, but let's
say this is homologous pair 2
right here, if the eye color
gene is here and here, remember
both homologous
chromosomes code for
the same genes.
They might have different
versions.
Those are alleles.
And if teeth are over here,
they will assort
independently.
So after meiosis occurs to
produce the gametes, the
offspring might get this
chromosome or a copy of that
chromosome for eye color and
might get a copy of this
chromosome for teeth
size or tooth size.
Or it could go the other way.
Maybe another offspring gets
this one, this chromosome for
eye color, and then this
chromosome for teeth color and
gets the other version
of the allele.
So because they're on different
chromosomes, there's
no linkage between if you
inherit this one, whether you
inherit big teeth, whether
you're going to inherit small
brown eyes or blue eyes.
Now, if they were on the same
chromosomee-- let's say the
situation where they are
on the same chromosome.
So let me pick another
trait: hair color.
Let's say the gene for hair
color is on chromosome 1, so
let's say hair color, the
gene is there and there.
These might be different
versions of hair color,
different alleles, but the
genes are on that same
chromosome.
In this situation, if someone
gets-- let's say if this is
blue eyes here and this is blond
hair, then these are
going always travel together.
You're not going to have these
assort independently.
And these are called
linked traits.
Let me highlight that.
So these right there, those
are linked traits.
But for a second, and we'll talk
more about linked traits,
and especially sex-linked traits
in probably the next
video or a few videos from now,
but let's assume that
we're talking about traits that
assort independently, and
we cross two hybrids.
So this is called a
dihybrid cross.
Very fancy word, but it just
gives you an idea of the power
of the Punnett square.
So let's say both parents are--
so they're both hybrids,
which means that they both have
the dominant brown-eye
allele and they have the
recessive blue-eye allele, and
they both have the dominant
big-tooth gene and they both
have the recessive little
tooth gene.
So this is the genotype
for both parents.
Both parents are dihybrid.
They're hybrids for both
genes, both parents.
What are all the different
combinations for their children?
And I could have done this
without dihybrids.
I could have made one of them
homozygous for one of the
traits and a hybrid for the
other, and I could have done
every different combination,
but I'll do the dihybrid,
because it leads to a lot of our
variety, and you'll often
see this in classes.
So if I'm talking about the mom,
what are the different
combinations of genes that
the mom can contribute?
Well, the mom could contribute
the brown-- so for each of
these traits, she can only
contribute one of the alleles.
So she could contribute this
brown right here and then the
big yellow T, so this is one
combination, or she could
contribute the big brown and
then the little yellow t, or
she can contribute
the blue-eyed
allele and the big T.
So these are all the different
combinations that she could
contribute.
And then the final combination
is this allele and that
allele, so the blue eyes
and the small teeth.
So that's from mom.
And, of course, dad could
contribute the same different
combinations because dad
has the same genotype.
Let me write that down.
Let me just write it like this
so I don't have to keep
switching colors.
Actually, I want to make them
a little closer together
because I'm going to run
out of space otherwise.
Nope.
Let me do it like that.
OK, brown eyes, so the dad could
contribute the big teeth
or the little teeth, z along
with the brown-eyed gene, or
he could contribute the
blue-eyed gene, the blue-eyed
allele in combination with the
big teeth or the yellow teeth.
Not the yellow teeth,
the little teeth.
That would be a different gene
for yellow teeth or maybe
that's an environmental
factor.
So these are all the different
combinations that can occur
for their offspring.
So let's draw-- call this maybe
a super Punnett square,
because we're now dealing
with, instead of four
combinations, we have
16 combinations.
It looks like I ran out
of ink right there.
It's strange why--
16 combinations.
Let me write that out.
Something's wrong
with my tablet.
Maybe there's something weird.
OK, so there's 16 different
combinations, and let's write
them all out, and I'll just
stay in one maybe neutral
color so I don't have
to keep switching.
I could get this combination,
so this brown eyes from my
mom, brown eyes from my dad
allele, so its brown-brown,
and then big teeth from both.
I could have this combination,
so I have capital B
and a capital B.
And then I have a capital
T and a lowercase t.
And then let's just keep
moving forward.
So I could get a capital B and a
lowercase B with a capital T
and a capital T, a big B,
lowercase B, capital T
lowercase t.
And I'm just going to go through
these super-fast
because it's going to take
forever, so capital B from
here, capital B from there;
capital T, lowercase t from
here; capital B from each and
then lowercase t from each.
You have a capital B and then
a lowercase b from that one,
and then a capital T from the
mom, lowercase t from the dad.
Hopefully, you're not getting
too tired here.
And so then you have the capital
B from your dad and
then lowercase b
from your mom.
Two lowercase t's-- actually
let me just pause and fill
these in because I don't want
to waste your time.
There I have saved you some time
and I've filled in every
combination similar to what
happens on many cooking shows.
But now that I've filled
in all the different
combinations, we can talk a
little bit about the different
phenotypes that might
be expressed from
this dihybrid cross.
For example, how many of these
are going to exhibit brown
eyes and big teeth?
So big teeth, brown-eyed kids.
Let me write this down here.
So if I want big teeth
and brown eyes.
All of a sudden, my pen
doesn't-- brown eyes.
So how many are there?
Big teeth and brown eyes.
So they're both dominant, so if
you have either a capital B
or a capital T in any of them,
you're going to have big teeth
and brown eyes, so this is
big teeth and brown eyes.
Big teeth right here,
brown eyes there.
Or maybe I should just say
brown eyes and big teeth
because that's the order that
I wrote it right here.
Brown eyes and big teeth, brown
eyes and big teeth.
Even though I have a recessive
trait here,
the brown eyes dominate.
I had a small teeth here, but
the big teeth dominate.
This is brown eyes
and big teeth.
Let's see, this is brown eyes
and big teeth, brown eyes and
big teeth, and let me see,
is that all of them?
Well, no.
This is brown eyes
and little teeth.
This is brown eyes and big teeth
right there, and this is
also brown eyes and big teeth.
They're heterozygous for each
trait, but both brown eyes and
big teeth are dominant, so these
are all phenotypes of
brown eyes and big teeth.
So how many of those
do we have?
We have one, two, three,
four, five, six, seven,
eight, nine of those.
So we have nine.
Nine brown eyes and big teeth.
Now, how many do we
have of big teeth?
Let me write in a different
color, so let me write brown
eyes and little teeth.
Something on my pen tablet
doesn't work
quite right over there.
So brown eyes and
little teeth.
So let's see, this
is brown eyes and
little teeth right there.
This is brown eyes and little
teeth right there.
So there's three combinations
of brown
eyes and little teeth.
And if I were to say blue eyes,
blue and big teeth, what
are the combinations there?
Well, this is blue eyes and big
teeth, blue eyes and big
teeth, so there's three
combinations there.
And if I want to be recessive on
both traits, so if I want--
let me do this.
I want blue eyes, blue
and little teeth.
There's only one.
Out of the 16, there's only one
situation where I inherit
the recessive trait from both
parents for both traits.
So if you look at this, and
you say, hey, what's the
probability-- there's only
one of that-- what's the
probability of having a big
teeth, brown-eyed child?
And these are all
the phenotypes.
There were 16 different
possibilities here, right?
There are 16 squares here, and
9 of them describe the
phenotype of big teeth
and brown eyes, so
there's a 9/16 chance.
So it's 9 out of 16 chance
of having a big
teeth, brown-eyed child.
What's the probability
of a blue-eyed
child with little teeth?
1 in 16.
So hopefully, in this video,
you've appreciated the power
of the Punnett square, that it's
a useful way to explore
every different combination of
all the genes, and it doesn't
have to be only one trait.
It can be in this case where
you're doing two traits that
show dominance, but they assort
independently because
they're on different
chromosomes.
You could use it-- where'd
I do it over here?
You could use it to explore
incomplete dominance when
there's blending, where red and
white made pink genes, or
you can even use it when there's
codominance and when
you have multiple alleles,
where it's not just two
different versions of the genes,
there's actually three
different versions.
So hopefully, you've
enjoyed that.